you curse in your private life you do
not you really don't no how do you
resist I don't know what is the purpose
no that's the sign of a smart person I
have such a limited vocabulary I have to
curse yeah I believe intelligent people
but you never get what do you say when
you get angry oh dang it oh shucks
really you've never cursed I don't think
so is that a religious thing or it's
just I don't know it's just way I was
brought up the way your parents raised
you they never cursed or anything no
speaking of your parents and I hope you
don't mind me bringing this up because
this is sad
um your parents died in a very strange
way you lost them because uh there was a
faulty carbon monoxide
um uh detector in the house right and
and it was a carbon monoxide poisoning
was it a faulty piece of equipment or
they never had one yeah I don't think
they ever had one so yeah I would
encourage people definitely get carbon
monoxide detectors because that would
probably saved my parents life yeah and
where does carbon monoxide in other
words in the house how does that occur
they uh well with my parents they uh
they had started a fire and I guess the
flu was closed they went to bed and they
never woke up oh my God and then the the
the the the the strange thing you got
the news and you had a show booked yeah
you had I was in the middle of a tour
you were in the middle of a tour yeah
and you said yeah I mean we've I've got
to deal with this but people have bought
tickets and you went out and performed
you were you know do a live performance
can you block that out can you pop
compartmentalize so well that that's
what I had to do I mean you know
um I'm a real The Show Must Go On kind
of guy yeah
um and uh you know it's not just me it
was like you know I travel with a band
and a crew uh I've got you know people
out there that have changed their lives
in order to come to these shows yeah
um and you know I I just had a yeah I
just heard of like for two hours every
night I just had to pretend like
everything was okay yeah I mean you
don't say anything to the audience or
anything you know I wasn't going to say
anything because I figured like you know
this is a very private matter and and I
don't want people to like be part of my
pain but like within hours of it
happening it was like international news
it was all over CNN and people knew
right uh so so basically you know uh I
think we put something on the screen
before the show to say that you know the
the show is going to be uh in memory of
my parents and right just to kind of
because that was you know does that sit
out of the way is the audience different
when they get I mean you you're the guy
who's like the fun guy at the party
you'll put a lampshade on your head
you'll play the accordion and you'll
you'll goof around but when something
like that when a notice goes up I'm sure
you're kind of concerned that wow this
is the end of the audience isn't going
to want to laugh right I mean it's a
tough situation it got some Applause and
then people were like okay now let's
enjoy the show yeah uh but yeah it was
it was definitely really tough I kind of
like you know I didn't do any meet and
greet I didn't want to like hang out
knowing it was just sort of like I just
kind of
you know two hours on on stage and then
just sort of like went into my own world
I can't think of anything more painful
because it's such a just a waste you
know like a [ __ ] fireplace you know
it's just it's just so sad did you go to
a psychiatrist for that no nothing no
you didn't need help negotiating that
well just going on just getting the
support from the fans actually was very
therapeutic I mean I know that sounds
corny no not to me it doesn't but it
really you know because a lot of people
have told me that that my music has
helped them during a very dark period in
their life right uh and it was I thought
well maybe it can do the same for me and
it actually did
foreign